first let's turn to a topic that many
democrats
always love to politicize and want to
talk about
especially every two and four years and
that's racism in america serious topic
most americans though are not racist
most americans
deplore uh racism they
are they see people of what they are as
ignorant
horrible evil people we you know that
they exist in the world yes they do but
that's not the majority of people
thankfully
most people want nothing to do with
these people but for the left for
democrats
as we have chronicled many times on this
program we know we can predict every two
years every four years
they will play the race card uh so that
they can win
elections and now unfortunately it's
gotten worse it's now become an almost
daily obsession a political weapon that
divides the country
the left sees racism around every turn
behind every wall
ingrained into every system in our
country and all throughout our entire
society
the only place they don't seem to notice
racism is when it's a democrat
or inside the democratic party where it
does exist for example
now the democrats have a slight majority
in the u.s senate
they are openly referring to the
legislative filibuster as
racist they are calling that a relic of
jim crow
they've been using that analogy a lot
lately but get this
we did our research democrats used this
so-called
racist jim crow relic a whopping
806 times since 2001
almost 600 times in the last three years
in fact they used it more than
republicans
way more than republicans apparently
it's
just racist when oh republicans do it
not when democrats do it
we see a similar trend with the georgia
election bill
for example led by stacey abrams rafael
warnock and
yes the ever weak frail cognitively
uh struggling joe biden democrats across
the country
with their friends in the media mob they
basically have accused
the entire state of georgia being racist
republicans in the state of georgia
being racist
they're claiming that georgians have
disenfranchised minority voters
when just the opposite is true and keep
in mind the state of delaware
joe's home state where joe's represented
people
over 8 000 years the voting laws
are far more restricted he's never
lifted a finger
to make them less restrictive to make
voting more accessible in his own state
look at your screen georgia mandates 17
days
of early in-person voting delaware has
no
in-person early voting and georgia
anyone can vote absentee but in delaware
you've got to meet several requirements
in georgia drop boxes for absentee
ballots they're in every county
in delaware they have zero drop boxes
for absentee ballots
and guess what both states including
joe's state
require voter id delaware is run by
democrats
it's joe biden's home state he's
represented them for
all century after century and apparently
delaware's voting laws are just fine
and not racist at all and then there's
democratic senator sheldon whitehouse of
rhode island
now he's frequently been lecturing
americans on how they can
better root out systemic racism but when
senator whitehouse was asked about his
family's membership
in a what's called an all-white beach
club well this is what he had to say
you decide has there been any traction
in that are there any minority members
of the club now
i think the people who are running the
place are still working on that i'm
sorry it hasn't happened
yet your thoughts on an elite all-white
wealthy club again in this day and age
um
you know should these clubs continue to
exist
it's a long tradition in rhode island
and there are many of them
and i think we just need to work our way
through the issues thank you
a long tradition that you are a part of
and won't get out of
if democrat belongs to an all-white club
it's just a long tradition
that's your answer we have issues to
work through
how many years have you been a member of
that club because
if anybody watching any republican said
that
they would be tarred they would be
feathered by the
democrats and the media mob and they'd
be canceled on the spot
but it gets worse just breaking tonight
foxnews.com has now reported
that there is another example about
senator whitehouse
and that he belongs to another
predominantly white club it's the local
yacht club
unfortunately unfortunately for senator
whitehouse
oh i guess fortunately he's a democrat
he's get he's gotten a free pass
he's going to remain getting a free pass
no democrats going to hold him
accountable
you're not going to call him a racist
you're not gonna demand that he
he stay out of the way anyway is he
standing up for
uh any african-americans by being
members of these clubs
or what about the african-american
lawmaker byron donalds remember
he was denied entry into the
congressional black caucus
i didn't know it was the congressional
black liberal caucus
but the cbc is discriminating against an
african-american in this case
mr donald's because of his political
beliefs
he's a republican he's a conservative he
released a statement
he wrote quote as a young black man that
grew up in
the inner city of brooklyn new york in a
single parent household
my achieving of the american dream would
be a valued addition to the cbc
and one that should transcend politics
he's absolutely right
apparently the content of his character
is not enough for the cbc
now the congressional black caucus
frankly they should be ashamed of
themselves
but sadly we have all seen this movie
play out
many times before most recently with
senator tim scott of south carolina we
saw it happen with clarence thomas
we've seen it happen pretty much to any
african-american
who is a conservative the members of the
cbc i guess
as a requirement you've got to be a
liberal democrat
and clearly there's no tolerance for any
differences politically
if you're a democratic if you're a
democrat racism apparently is tolerated
look at the rhode island senator if
you're a republican if you're a
conservative
you are excoriated you are canceled
you are beaten up by the media mob by
big tech by the democratic party
perfect case in point is joe biden and
i'm going to get to him and explain his
history with race in a minute
now let's look at this critical race
theory debate in the country
now this anti-american belief structure
that is rooted in marxism
it claims that white people are
collectively all guilty of racism from
birth
just because they're white democrats
want to teach this to every student in
every school
in america they want them to learn this
radical ideology
from an early age schools that can't
even teach kids reading writing math and
science
yeah they care seemingly more about
political indoctrination
parents in loudoun county in virginia
are rightly tonight
outraged this kind of far left
indoctrination
is creeping into their school system
yesterday the school board shut down
all public comments at their local
meeting two men were arrested
uh one for simply refusing to leave
what was an open session for parents
these parents had every right to be
worried
they have every right to be heard uh
especially on dealing with critical race
theory and
other far left ideologies uh what is
this now
you know socialism cloaked and race
indoctrinate
everybody into group think at a very
early age
the end goal is what how does this help
bring america together is this divide
america
or does this bring us together does this
reform america
or does it dismantle the entire system
i'm not sure that's going to work this
country succeeds
with something called freedom and
individualism
and capitalism and personal freedom
not collective guilt not judging people
by the content
by the color of their skin but by the
content of their character
what they are teaching and what they are
preaching is the antithesis
of what martin luther king dreamed of
that was a colorblind society
one that did judge people by the content
of their character not the color of
their skin
democrats think they're immune to racism
therefore their beloved critical race
theory
can't possibly be racist now make no
mistake democrats are
anything but immune to racism now
remember democrats
they elected this guy as president less
than a year ago
take a look madam president we have
predators
on our streets the largest growth in
population
is indian americans moving from india
you cannot go to a 7-11
are a dunkin donuts unless you have a
slight indian accent
what kind of a chance would a
northeastern liberal like joe biden
stand
uh in the south better than anybody else
and you don't know my state my state was
a slave state
you got the first sort of
mainstream freaking american
who was articulate and bright and
clean and a nice looking guy i mean this
that's a story
they're going to put you all back in
chains we got more questions
you got more questions but i tell you if
you have a problem figuring out whether
you're for me or
trump and you ain't black so joe gets a
pass why he's a democrat a liberal
democrat
now today i penned another op-ed to the
new york times our friends ben smith
maggie haberman
they need to give back the pulitzer by
the way other so-called journalists at
the new york times they're not
journalists
they are liberal radical new green deals
socialist
activists they're the press office for
the democrats they've never covered
biden's racist past
is the times concerned with joe biden's
prior work in the senate
with segregationists he wanted to stop
the integration of schools stop school
busing
does the new york times approve of of
biden's eulogy for the former klansmen
robert byrd where he praised
robert byrd and his incredible esteem
does the new york times think
it's appropriate that biden openly
worried at a senator
if we had integration of schools in
america that our children would be going
to schools that are
racial jungles his words is the times
aware that joe biden co-authored the 94
crime bill
after referring to inner city residents
as predators on our streets
do they care about any of the racist
rhetoric from biden that we just played
do they care that his son has used the
n-word and made many
anti-asian slurs himself that just
became
revealed in the last few weeks or does
none of this matter to the new york
times
or the rest of the media mob just
because joe
biden is a democrat he gets a pass now
ultimately most on the left
they don't really care about racism only
if they can politicize it
lives matter but only when they get to
politicize it
for them it's a means to an end on the
left race is a political tool
they use it to take down their enemies
they give a pass to the people that
share their viewpoint
it's not clear that joe biden even
understands any of this
he was quite clearly struggling again
cognitively
and now he does where you know whatever
his my far left mind
wanders asks of him true to form they
put joe in a meeting today with a bunch
of people
he didn't seem to remember and when joey
sippy cup
tried to blame guns for the rising
violence in america's inner cities well
here's what happened trace illegal gun
sales
back to a shady gun dealer and hold them
accountable
police chief murray of the baltimore
excuse me
police chief mayor police chief
murphy paul of baton rouge louisiana
talked about attorney general greenwald
new jersey
and mayor daniel and mayor daniela
levine cava of miami-dade talked about
their efforts to lift up those kinds of
community
the kinds of community programs that
reduce gun violence
did any of that make sense to you first
they come for the second amendment
then they'll come for the first